residents came out in force in the
turkish border province of hatai about a
thousand people joined the
demonstrations against terrorism after
sunday's bombings
we buried my cousin this morning there
was more a massacre than an ordinary
bombing
it was done to create chaos
turkish prime minister erdogan stressed
that he wouldn't be drawn into a
knee-jerk reaction he made a plea for
calm
most importantly we have to keep our
cool against all kinds of provocation or
agitation that tries to pull turkey into
the war in syria
in spite of that ankara is keeping its
options open and hasn't ruled out taking
military action
the investigation into the bombings has
already led to nine arrests and more are
expected
thanks to our intelligence agencies and
support from ankara nine people were
taken into custody last night
some were involved in the planning
they stored the vehicles
the suspects are turkish citizens but
officials say the group has links to the
syrian intelligence agency and president
basar al-assad's regime
the syrian government denies any
involvement
it was turkey that transformed the
syrian turkish border region into
concentrations of international
terrorism
they turned the houses of civilian turks
their farms and properties into a center
and a passageway for terrorist groups
but now citizens of hate fear the war in
syria will spill across the border